warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised
what's up everybody welcome back to LED
live today we're gonna be talking about
is there a danger to having a celebrity
crush find out on this episode of LED
live what's up everybody we got Eric
Wilson with us again today and he's
gonna be talking about the seduction of
soul ties and what kind of dangers are
involved with that but first we want to
thank our patreon donors without you
guys there's no way this show could be
possible and we cannot thank you guys
enough
if you would like to support this
ministry you can click the link below
and become a patreon as well and you'll
get early access and you can get behind
the scenes footage find out what we're
up to and a lot of other cool things
like a t-shirt that nobody else can get
besides that you can also buy the
t-shirts that help us out we got a lot
of cool designs they come in all kinds
of colors and shapes and sizes of all
sorts also we are gonna do a patreon
show after this so if you are a patreon
you'll get an exclusive little after
talk about the law of attraction and is
it it's gonna be the law of attraction
what's the secret there you go what's
the secret also we are expanding our
ministry into the Spanish world so if
you have any spanish-speaking family or
friends please click the link below to
little light studios es and share our
Spanish channel with them we're gonna be
translating all our shows over time so
that they will get to see that as well
and we thank you for your support and
we'd like to get into this show so so
what's going on Eric Wilson what do you
got for us
it's good to be back here over the last
couple of shows we've done together
we've been really taking a look at
spiritualism in some different forms you
know how Satan and evil spirits are
trying to take God's throne in man's
heart so what we're going to be looking
at today is as you mentioned celebrity
crushes you know what happens when you
when you really look at somebody
in the wrong way with desire on TV I
mean a lot of people are like well you
know I know I'm a Christian
I'm just I'm it's on television I'm just
watching you just cuz I think she's good
looking at you I want to look or him
look don't touch yes and I've heard
something that really bothered me I
heard a couple of Christian women one
time say this as I was sitting in a park
they were having a conversation in front
of me and they were all giggling and
laughing and then some guy walked by and
one of the ladies and these ladies are
my age they said who wouldn't that some
eye candy and these all these women
profess to be Christians and I thought
hi candy it's like going in and looking
but not touching so it's okay to look
and desire as long as you don't actually
go through the act you would not believe
how many Christians believe that but the
Bible says the heart has to be purified
and I know as a young man I can remember
when I was 13 14 years old and I started
in high school I went to church every
you know week with my my mom and that
was the struggle that was a little
reason that I walked away from church
for so many years was my mom was like
Eric you know what's wrong why do you
wanna leave Church and I told her I said
mom I said I go to church every single
week and I'm hearing the same things
over and over again but it has not
helped me to not want some girl that's
walking by in a short skirt right you
know or if you go to the swimming pool
or to the beach I mean there's all these
people running around and less than
their underwear how do you overcome that
and unfortunately I wasn't exposed to
help that would show me how Christ can
come inside of my heart and change my
very nature so what we're gonna look at
today is that yes exactly why we do this
channel we want to tackle the tough
topics that millennia you know the young
generation are dealing with it they're
not getting at church you know some of
the taboo topics so we're glad that
you're going to do this well I do praise
God we do have men that are starting to
speak about these things and there's
also women that are teach
you know on this so we need to kind of
baby steps you know one thing leads to
another and it's like you do well on
that so long it can lead to pornography
that's a good night and so for
pornography I recommend a couple of
resources one as a resource by Scott
Richmond he has a serious Cola greater
lust
what you see on the screen now is a
cocaine addicts brain compared with a
pornography addicts brain which one
looks worse which one looks like it has
more holes and areas of non
functionality it's bewitching it's a
species of witchcraft
from a Christian point of view because
we know that the devil is the true one
behind this and another one is a
cinematic film that I seen not too long
ago it's actually really well done it's
called the heart of man that was really
powerful so check those out if this is a
an area that you're struggling with and
a lot of guys are we're just being
realistic so those are because resources
that might help you so I also heard of a
channel called a YouTube channel called
fight the new drug is that the one that
Scotty was showing us yeah yeah that I'm
told is really good it's not Christian
at least not overtly or outwardly the
principles might be I don't know I
haven't watched that one but I've heard
good things about it
that's fight the new drug yeah
definitely anti-porn and yeah at least
addiction all that exactly and and we
weren't even going to go there but since
Keith brought that up up I want to
encourage everybody out there in the
statistics that we have seen you know
within ministry right now those that
would admit to it on paper over 50% of
the Christian pastors in the United
States admit they're addicted to
pornography pastors that's right so if
that's the pastor's think about the
congregation's and this is men and women
used to be like when I was growing up it
was like it will only men you know abuse
themselves but now it's as common for
women as it is for men I want to share
something with you don't think don't
listen to the lies the devil's telling
you that God does not love you because
you're in bondage right it does not mean
that God is going to let you get into
heaven staying in that condition but it
means that he loves you so much that if
you will trust in him and seek Him he
will set you free man your view of God
can keep you from coming to God amen and
that's what God doesn't want you know
like just like in the garden you know
Adam and Eve the first thing they do is
hide and God is coming to meet with them
and he asked them a question that is it
seems kind of ridiculous if your God
like right you know he says where are
you it's not a geographical location
question at least it's not in my mind
because God knows everything right he's
not asking well where are you at in the
garden but I can't find you know God is
asking where are you in relation to me
it's a relational question where are you
where are we at you know so that's what
God is asking many people today where
are you in relation to me and so I'd
encourage you to respond to God that's
what he wants he wants you to respond to
him and and restore that relationship so
don't ever think man I've done something
so horrible and terrible I can't come to
God no you can always come to God that's
what he's there for
amen amen I'm glad you brought that up
because that's important so the title of
this message this program is soul ties
seduction and the poison of serpents in
the Old Testament there was a story
right when Israel was about to go over
the Jordan River and they were gonna go
into Canaan Canaan was the promised land
now we know the Bible tells us that all
those things that happen unto them are
examples unto us upon whom the ends of
the world have come so for us as
Christians Canaan is not a location here
on this earth it's heaven it's going
home to our Father and our elder brother
our Savior Jesus Christ we're on the
very borders of Canaan today now listen
to what it says in first Corinthians
chapter 10 and Psalm 106 all these
things are our examples for the purpose
or to the intent that we should not lust
after evil things that means the word
lust means to desire or longed for
things that will cause you harm
you know people are like well that
wouldn't cause me harm well your body is
the temple of God is what you're eating
or what you're drinking
destroying that temple that's God's
temple it's what you're watching or
listening to is it destroying that
temple of God and then he says neither
let us commit fornication as some of
them committed and this shocked me
because I did not know this until the
past two years I was listening to a
preacher one day and he brought this up
and I'll never forget it you look up the
word fornication in a Strong's
Concordance or on a sword not in a
dictionary but in a something that will
show you what the original Greek word
was the word for fornication there is
pornea
it's where we get the word pornography
from all the way back there 2000 years
ago God was telling us neither let us
commit fornication and I thought about
that I was like okay so what's the
difference between adultery and
fornication adultery is it's like you're
forsaking your lawful wife in God's eyes
and you say I'm gonna go be another
person's mmm fornication is saying no
I'm not gonna forsake my wife this is
only a one-night stand
I'll do this tonight and God will
forgive me tomorrow you know I'll come
back tomorrow just I'm gonna be gone for
the night it's a it's a moment of
pleasure it's like you're selling
everything for a moment so he says
neither let us commit fornication as
some of them committed and there fell in
one day 23,000 men it says that when
they were on their way into Canaan and I
know Keith and I were talking about this
he had brought this story yet they were
on their way into Canaan and there was a
king that lived in Canaan and he saw
over a million and a half Israelites
coming from Egypt and all the Canaanites
had heard what God did for them in Egypt
and it terrified them because a million
and a half people that's huge and that's
a minimum they're coming out of Egypt
and the the
canaanite King Balak he said I've got to
do something about this we can't fight
these people especially with their God
so he hired a prophet named Balaam and
Balaam was supposed to be working for
God the New Testament indicates but he
hired him he said we want to pay you an
unbelievable amount of money to come and
curse Israel literally to curse Israel
it means to to speak a curse over them
which is empowered by their gods so
Balaam was like oh man I mean what's the
Lord gonna think about this and the
devil whispered to him and he sold out
he said the money is worth it maybe he
said maybe committed fornication and I
can repent tomorrow after I got the
money right so he he comes to curse them
and every time he opens his mouth to
speak a curse God puts words in his
mouth and blesses them
and you can read it in numbers I think
it was what numbers 20 or 19 or 23 I
don't remember the exact chapter but
it's in the Book of Numbers but finally
the king the pagan king was like shut up
don't say another word every time you
speak your blessing them and they're
getting stronger
he said just don't say anything and
Balaam went home and he thought about it
all night and the devil inspired him and
he got an idea he said you know how you
can destroy the children of God get him
to sin against him say went back the
next morning he told Balak he said I
know how you can get them he said they
there are pure people there holy he said
get all of your unmarried women to go
hold a party a festival or a feast
outside the camp far enough away that
you know you don't get in trouble for
doing it but close enough that they can
hear the sound so they can hear the
music plane and and be intrigued to go
look at it so twenty three thousand men
decide we got to go check this out
there's some danger we got to go to see
what this is and they see women that are
dressed different than the god-fearing
women and is
trill they hear sounds and music that's
different than god-fearing music and
they go in there seduced to come in and
it says that they sat down and they ate
and drink the girls were like oh we're
not gonna harm you you know just come
have dinner with us and the guys like oh
I mean yes signature I'm gonna witness
tool mmm so they go in and they start
quote witnessing and after a little
while the seduction the desire was
stimulated and when they were joined
physically with those women Psalms 106
verse 28 says they joined themselves
unto bail and they ate the sacrifices of
the Dead the dead are the Canaanites
they were dead in trespasses and sins so
they were eating things that had been
sacrificed to their gods they were
sleeping with and fornicating with their
women who worshiped those gods and they
were joined to bail and so not just
joined with the women but joined with
their false gods yes yes that's
terrifying yeah
and I know from my own life of mess ups
and failures and rebellion against God I
know what that does it can destroy you
that's why God doesn't want us to be
unequally yoked yeah that's a good point
the Bible tells us in 1st Corinthians
chapter 6 know ye not that he which is
joined to a harlot is one body for to
say if God shall be one flesh so now I'm
just going to give you an example and we
may have talked about this on one of our
former programs but I went to speak and
to share some of this information at a
church and I had a man come up to me and
he was in his 70s probably I'm guessing
early 70s early to mid seventies but he
came up afterward he said I'd really
like to talk to you one-on-one alone and
I said okay so we found the room and we
sat down and he said so what's wrong and
he said I was in Vietnam so you know I
mean this 50 years ago
and he said I was I claim to be a
Christian but I wasn't really living
like one and he said when I was there we
had a night where you know we could go
into town he said all the GIS went into
town to get drunk and play pool and
whatever and he said so I got drinking
and partying and stuff and he said I
wound up spending the night with a
prostitute
and he said you know in my mind I'm like
it's only one night I mean big deal he
said I came back and he said I have not
been able to be intimate with my wife
since that day he said every and he said
I had to tell her what happened he's I
confessed it to God he said that every
time that my wife and I tried to be
become what God wanted us to be he said
the memories of that night the sounds
the smell whatever he said I can't get
rid of it he said it's killing my wife
he said it's killing me that I hate what
I've done to my wife and I shared with
him what we're gonna talk about today
and and later on in these coming
programs about how to get free and now
for the first time in 50 years it's gone
praise Allah it's gone now the rest of
that verse says you know he that's
joined to a harlot is one body for two
saith he shall be one flesh but then it
says but he that is joined unto the Lord
is one spirit so if I am joined to a
prostitute or a harlot or an ungodly
person maybe she's not a prostitute or
maybe it's a male because the same thing
happens with male or female if I'm
joined to a woman and she's worshiping
bail well then bail has access to my
life but God promises this don't you
realize that if you're joined to the
Lord Jesus Christ the spirit that is in
him is now has access to you just like
the evil side that's that's the
counterfeit of what God wants to do so
God is like I want you to be were the
Bride of Christ the Bible says he's like
so be one with me so this is so
his problem right that's a good thing
right because Solomon he allowed himself
to be yoked to all these women who were
you know they had other gods and then
gained access to his life that is a guy
I did not think about you're right
because he had like a thousand
concubines or wives yeah and and it
really shows the risk that David was
taking you know that's a deeply an
Abraham any other patriarchs true yeah
Abraham you know it was told to sleep
with the hand made by his wife I mean
but there's still spiritual implications
to that even though they thought they're
doing it for a purpose to have a child
that you know it's weird because who he
slept with Hagar which was Sarah's
handmaid she was Egyptian sure she was
raised with a pagan religious background
I don't know if she had changed but
there was a there was a reason why the
Lord said that son that came from that
marriage or that joining that's not the
one right of your own flesh I'm gonna
bring forth aside so praise God and
sneak because that that statement he
that is joined to the Lord is one spirit
that's what the word atonement means at
one minute what happened at Calvary has
made us by faith if we believe it one
with Christ and one with God and greater
is He that is in us than he that's in
this world yep this is a slide that I
use normally when we're talking about
Hollywood and I know you guys just
released an led recently called
channeling spirits yeah and you guys had
went through and shown all these actors
that talked about the muse well we know
from the actors as well as from Socrates
that the muse is a demonic entity a
fallen spirit or fallen spirits
well here's estee lauder you know
perfume company and they have a product
that they call modern muse well a muse
if it's an evil spirit what is it trying
to inspire us with and you look at the
woman
it's advertising it so if it's my
Victoria's Secret all the women that
they used to advertise their products
you know yeah I mean it's just crazy
that we live in a day where like you
walk but you can't even go to the mall
cuz there's pictures ten-foot-tall of
women wearing lingerie you're exactly
right or you watch if you had like
mainstream cable you could be watching
what you feel like is an innocent show
or maybe the news or something else in
Victoria's Secret pops on you don't have
control of what image pops up on there
and then it's in your mind after that
that's right and now you know I hope I
don't offend people but at the same time
it's like it's the truth I'm sharing
with you what the Lord has revealed to
me that I struggled with I cannot
remember the last time that I went to
the beach I mean I do I know I don't
remember the date that I remember going
and I was there and my son and my
daughter were still little and I looked
around and I thought all these women
that are running around in bathing suits
are wearing less than what they have on
during the regular work week in their
undergarments and I thought okay so if I
went over to visit Keith and Keith was
like hey let's sit down here in the
living room my wife's getting dinner
ready and I was like okay so we're
sitting in the living room and his wife
walks out in her underwear and says
dinner's ready y'all want to come in I
mean I would fall over I mean and Keith
would he would knock me over if I didn't
but the point being is is that I would
not want to see another man's wife in
her underwear yeah why do I think it's
okay to go to the beach and see them
wearing less you know why it's the same
thing only they put a different label on
the tag oh this isn't underwear or
lingerie this is the bathing suit oh
okay that's okay it makes it Christian
your ass so I look at it I think you
know I'll tell my wife I'm like I don't
mind going if it's all guys getting
together to swim or if it's just my wife
and I swimming but there's no way I want
to go and look at other women or be
around that you're placing yourself in
their new temptation yeah you go in the
wintertime
like going to the Playboy Mansion Wow
this is something that caught me when I
was young because I knew at 14 years old
I was like okay so I can't commit
adultery and then I thought wait now I'm
not even married
okay I'm clean but I would go to school
and my conscience would convict me or if
I'd go to the mall or go to the park and
hang out with everybody after school my
conscience would convict me what are you
looking at and you're like okay I'm not
gonna look I'm gonna grit my teeth and
not look and then listen to what Jesus
said he said I say unto you that
whosoever looks on a woman with desire
after her has already committed adultery
with her in his heart and I didn't
really comprehend that until I saw the
film that Keith in and Mikey in them and
everybody did and Michelle did called
sued ology and they showed that they
have scientifically proven that what the
mind thinks about the body reacts as if
it's already done it know a lot of
people you know they're very particular
about their clone or their perfume and I
never realized it's not like people are
just in there in a laboratory with
chemicals going I wonder what that oh
it's terrible throw that when I was
trying nothing you know you could be
there for the rest of your life and not
get the right one when they develop
perfume and cologne they do it with
intention they know what smells will
trigger the release of chemicals and
hormones in the body it's not by chance
because you can have a woman that you
know you never even notice her and then
the next day she comes into the office
and she's wearing a different perfume
and all of a sudden it's like and she's
really attractive I've never noticed her
before it's just because the perfume
she's wearing right I've actually heard
that that's why they design guys perfume
and ladies perfume differently because
the guys perfume supposed to attract the
ladies and supposed to attract guys
that's exactly right
I remember being a kid seeing on like
Fox or something just regular mainstream
TV they're talking about the the smells
and how they affect people and they
that did these studies and I found out
that women were attracted to smells like
licorice and cucumbers yeah I guess it's
not what you would expect though like
I've never seen a perfume or I've never
seen a cologne that smell like licorice
and cucumbers but yeah it's weird how it
just smells you know our senses are so
powerful that you know like you were
saying it was it you yeah you were
talking yesterday about music how it
triggers like chemicals in your brain
and stuff right yeah yes so the same
thing and having with smells and they're
getting scientific about it yes so when
you look at that you know he said
whoever looks at a woman with desire has
already committed adultery with her
already and to say if he shall be one
flesh so that means like I've had I've
had people call me and they're like I
haven't committed adultery and I don't
and I'm like look you know and they say
well I've got this problem I'm
struggling in this area and I'm like
what are you watching on TV what are you
watching on the Internet and then you
get silence you know it's like I can
remember when I was a little boy there
was a TV show that came on called Buck
Rogers and I can remember the lady that
played the the female heroine it was
Erin gray was her name I believe that
was Erin gray but as a little boy I
thought she was beautiful and I loved I
look forward to watching that show when
it came on because I could see her yeah
and she never was like unclad or
anything but I just I got really
attracted to the way she looked well
what if what if she was a witch what if
she had a demon of anger or bitterness I
don't need to be attached to that and
have that thing coming in and trying to
mess up my life so it's really just
exploiting something that's very natural
inside of us yeah men men were designed
to be attracted to women no doubt about
that
you know the way a woman is made is
designed to attract a man the way a man
is made is designed to attract a woman
they're supposed to complement each
other a man's just exploiting what's
already there in a way that's unhealthy
for the
sickle spiritual emotional nature's
that's exactly right right as a woman we
feel uncomfortable if a guy looks a
certain way and you can tell yeah you
can tell so you can okay makes us sound
spiritual you're feeling the spirits of
his less skin that you know I mean like
I mean there's been people that I've met
before and you walk away you go
I don't need to talk to that person
anymore because there's there's
something there's a power of Attraction
there that is not natural it's something
else
flirtatious yeah or it's like the devil
going man if I could get these two
together we could really make a mess of
some lives you know and sometimes you're
just clueless yeah guys in particular
sometimes a girl's interesting he's just
no idea I remember there's a girl in
college she was interested in me and I
didn't really pick up on it for a long
time but she was she was into Wiccan I
know Wow but I had no interest who's not
not anybody praise God
yeah this there might not be any
connection at all but I just thought of
this to ask like when people say I'm
having this problem or whatever is there
any similarities and the problems
they're having like when they have this
struggle does it have always a have the
same kind of effects in their life
you mean are they like common symptoms
for the same spiritual entity
influencing yes really yeah it's always
if we don't this I don't think we will
in this one we may try to do some of
that in the other one the second part
it's almost like if you've got a
sickness the first thing a doctor
normally would do is don't run bloodwork
tell me what your symptoms are right
this is probably what it is
so a lot of times with spiritual issues
the same thing happens it's like it may
not always you have to let the Lord lead
you in I mean you always pray because
I'm like God I don't know anything I
can't see the heart yeah but you can see
some things that normally are
manifestations of a spiritual influence
in a person's life and I'll use just a
calm
I've had a lot of you know men that have
contacted me about this if there is
extreme where it seems like there's a
hole in the bottom of the bucket I
gather money and it's like it doesn't
matter what I'm doing it keeps just it's
like it's gone and I don't know where it
went often not always but often the
Bible says that through whoredom or
through fornication a man is brought to
a piece of bread and there's another
verse I'll have to find where it is it's
in the Old Testament but it also talks
about it's like put he's pouring money
into a bucket and there's a hole in the
bottom so it's like no matter what you
do you never seem to be able to get out
of that that rut and a lot of times that
can be what it is I've had another
another man that has called me and this
was common but he said you know my wife
and I is just like you know we we don't
physically fight but there's always this
anger and bitterness and stress and we
had something that someone had shared
with my wife and I because we went
there's some similar problems like that
and they said something they said it's
common if a couple are like on the verge
of getting married and they go you know
what we're not gonna have sex we're not
gonna go all the way but we're gonna
fool around I mean we're getting married
anyway we got two months to go that's
still a sin against God even though
you're already committed to the marriage
you're committing fornication that is a
sin and one of the things that that
spirit of fornication will do is once
the marriage marriage is made it will
start causing bitterness oftentimes a
girl if she's still a virgin if she's
still pure even though she's in love
with this man and she says oh we're
gonna get married anyway spiritual
entities will cause her to feel like you
defiled me because that covenant was not
made yet so it's like you know I had to
go
my wife was pure when her and I got
married I wasn't I was a terrible person
before you know I gave my life to the
crime you know to Christ and I had to go
to my wall
I said I'm sorry and I laid out door I
said this is what I've done to you I'm
sorry for what I've done I'm sorry for
all the hurt I brought and I went to the
Lord and I confessed it to him between
he and I and I asked for his forgiveness
ask for her forgiveness and God wiped
the slate clean I mean like going praise
God he can do that so you did verify
something that I was told then cuz I
remember studying with a guy and and I
was living with my wife before we were
married and and that got brought up and
I I was like what is wrong with you know
because yeah to me it was like Mary's
just a piece of paper or a legal
document you know but that's what he
said he said well according to the Bible
I know where he got it from but he said
according to the Bible he you just can't
be blessed the way God wants to bless
you or something and it seemed like some
of it was financial and stuff - that's
weird
I'd like to see where that came from
okay I want to show you something here
because we were talking about cosmetics
and things this is an advertisement for
a fairly new cosmetic company called
Urban Decay mmm now for me when I first
saw this I was like that's shocking
because normally people think cosmetics
are there to make you look better why do
you want something that says decay but
then I made the mistake of looking on
their website just to see what their
company was about and they are trying to
encourage or seduce women to make
themselves look like those kinds of
women that you find in those parts of
town the parts where the pool halls are
and the tattoo parlors and the houses of
ill-repute and you know what I'm talking
about so that they promote that it's
funny because this one is an
advertisement for one of their mascara
line it's called perversion mascara
bigger blacker batter lashes so
everything that they're that they're
advertising with they're using words
that are talking about things that we
know are of Satan and not of the okay
and perversion batter yes I showed this
to Scotty one day what's the oh wow
sinful colors fearless colors so it's
it's some kind of makeup I'm not sure it
may be eyeshadow or something I think
yeah
sinful colors and people have to use a
word like sin I mean that's just
biblical language yeah where's that says
Keith that they'll call light darkness
and darkness light and sin they'll call
good and sweet I don't remember where
that is but it says that but the Lord
has told us in the last days he said
it's gonna be just like it was from the
days of Noah before the flood and it'll
be just like the days of Sodom and
Gomorrah 5:20 what was it Isaiah 5:20
would you read that for us
sure what are those who call evil good
and good evil who put darkness for light
and light for darkness who put bitter
for sweet and sweet for bitter and
that's what we see happening today this
is like oh I want those sinful colors I
want the bigger badder perversion but
you know what what I found is that Satan
does not want us to know who we really
are yeah sons and daughters of God it's
like I think about I asked sometimes you
know whenever we have a congregation or
an audience wherever I'm speaking I say
be honest with me tell me who is the
most attractive woman that you know now
in the media and you I get all kinds of
responses excuse me you know gal Gaga or
Beyonce or whoever and then I'll ask the
women what about who would you say is
the most attractive you know man
you know when I was growing up it was
like Arnold Schwarzenegger or Clint
Eastwood or something you know but
nowadays it's it's other actors that
people look up to but I think what are
what would those people think like if
they come up in the second resurrection
lost and there's Adam and Eve standing
beside them I mean all these beautiful
women with all their makeup are gonna
look at Eve and go
they're gonna be covering themselves in
shine because she had a perfect figure I
mean she was part with no makeup no junk
hanging from her ear she was perfect and
Adam he's like I never lifted weights
and he's gonna be you know who knows how
tall and a perfect physique listen when
it says in Proverbs for the lips of a
strange woman that means not your wife
you know the Bible says they lust after
strange flesh strange means it's not
your own because when you're married the
two become one the lips of a strange
woman drop as a honeycomb her mouth or
her words are smoother than oil but her
end is bitter as wormwood and as sharp
as a two-edged sword for her feet go
down to death and her steps take hold on
Hell lusts not after her beauty in thine
heart neither let her take thee with her
eyelids how many times do you notice in
advertising it's the eyes yeah they know
if I can get an eye look like looking at
you looking at the camera they got you
the Lord says neither let her take thee
with her eyelids for by means of a
[__] woman a man is brought to a
piece of bread they'll destroy you I
mean I know people that were making 60
70 80 thousand dollars a year and
because of whoredom and fornication even
just through the internet or their
television they were brought to where
they had nothing this is another
advertisement from urban urban decay and
the the model that they had chosen to be
their icon is a woman named Ruby Rose
now that name
now I'm gonna be careful and you'll
understand why as we get to the end of
this program I'm gonna be careful how we
talk about her because God loves the
sinner and but he hates the sins right
and you know what I learned a few years
ago that really has helped me
the reason God hates the sin is because
it's destroying the one he loves I mean
he hates when he sees something that's
destroying us and when I saw God that
way it changed me before I was like God
hates me because I did this he hates me
because I'm no he doesn't hate you he
hates what you're doing because it's
killing you the one he loves this
advertisement for lipstick it's called
Vice lipstick
I mean Vice is like every kind of bad
you know the vice squad are the ones
that deal with prostitution and drugs
and and murder and violence but that's
how they're advertising this yeah oh you
gotta read more than that like go ahead
you reader prepare to get hooked of ice
a hundred addictive shades fully loaded
you know I'm gonna get loaded tonight
all there were in six indulgent and
don't do something we shouldn't be we
should be tempering six indulgent
finishes Wow it's seductive just the
words are seductive they know that every
time this woman Ruby Rose was also the
actress that was chosen to play in the
new Batman TV show series good woman
that one I'm sorry bat woman yeah so she
did the first season and since the same
thing now she's she's gonna leave the
show and I understanding and she's gonna
be replaced by somebody else okay I
think they're looking to replace her
with somebody who has similar viewpoints
on sexuality okay this is an article
from The Guardian and this is the title
it says that woman lesbian superhero
gets her own TV show now they're saying
here not that the actress is which she
openly admits that she is bisexual but
they're saying that the character of bat
woman is a lesbian care
so that that's weird they promote it you
know because if this is just a personal
preference or whatever why's that it's
night it's not Batwoman superhero gets
their own show Batman our bat woman
lesbian superhero like why do you
advertise that as you know that's like
labeling the superheroes a lesbian yeah
weird this is what they go on to say and
I'm not gonna read the whole thing but I
want to get this one part it says Kate
Kane who is the bat woman's name when
she's not you know that woman is an out
lesbian
that means she's come out of the closet
she's open about it who has arrived in
Gotham to handle a citywide resurgence
in crime but don't call her a hero yet
reached the show synopsis in a city that
is desperate for a savior Kate must
overcome her own demons before embracing
the call to be Gotham symbol of hope
make a note of that because that's what
they say about this character make a
note of that because when we get to the
end it's gonna be really clear Savior of
hope that has to fight our own demons
first yeah
Marvel and DC Comics and I know the
little light has already done some
powerful documentary on this like with
the replacement gods volume 1 and volume
2 if you have not seen those they are
worth purchasing that was probably
replacement gods number 1 was probably
my second favorite documentary they've
ever done it was really really strong
but listen to what what the the director
x-men director Bryan Singer is recorded
as saying he not only directed most of
the x-men movies but he recruited an
openly gay activist actor Ian McKellen
and he's the one that played magneto
in a number of the series and he also
was the actor that played Gandalf and
Lord of the Rings do you know when I've
heard oh no no no when I first came to
Christ when I first came back from the
darkness
I was watching Lord
the Rings I was like this is so cool
there's so many biblical similarities
you know here's this horde of evil
coming against the good guys and on the
third day I think it was here comes
Gandalf riding a white horse leading the
armies of good and I was like this is so
cool and I had no idea what I was saying
it only appears angel Satan always makes
himself appear as an angel of light
right and I didn't know that the actor
Ian McKellen is an openly gay advocating
or homosexual advocating actor it says
that actor Ian McKellen to star as
magneto he could he got him to star as
magneto by convincing him that the
mutants were comparable to struggling
gays they were trying to come out of the
closet and maybe there's some behind
that being called x-men and you never
know McKellen stated I think and this is
what Ian McKellen said I think that
Bryan Singer expected I was going to
consider it not a posh enough job but he
revealed that he was told that the x-men
is really about lesbian gay bisexual and
transgender people and here's a picture
of Ian McKellen and this is one of his
close male friends Patrick Stewart who
played Star Trek he was what was his
name pic pic hard yeah in the Star Trek
series they were both an x-men oh yes
that's right that's a good point
both of them are openly homosexual and
there when I say they're male friends I
mean there's more there than should be
yep which is sad because I think these
poor men you look in their eyes and
there's no joy there's darkness there's
darkness so that means we need to pray
for them McKellen says the end McKellen
said I thought he was right it's not
just a fantasy story it's a parable the
x-men McKellen is also a Cove
founder of the LGBT gay activist group
called Stonewall and this was something
that was founded back in the 60s and 70s
like with the topic of having a
celebrity crush it's like people think
what's innocent you know I'm not I'm
looking but I'm not touching and what
we're trying to show is is that all is
not what you see is not everything
that's there you're just seeing what's
the mask true you don't know what's
behind the mask and I hate to say it but
the same thing happens at church I've
had people that have contacted me and
they're like there they have a celebrity
crush with someone at church you know
and you're like and you know that that
pastor is such a he's good-looking he's
outgoing he's got good personality he
knows the Bible and you don't know what
is going on in his life at home
even if he's single and she's single you
don't know what's going on inside him
behind the mask yeah on this show we've
heard about pastors that have been
pastoring for years and find out they're
abusing children and everything yeah you
really don't know or maybe it's this
attractive lady in your Sabbath School
or Sunday School class and you think man
I always enjoy going because I like to
look at her and think about her and but
you don't know what's actually in her
life so if you are joined to somebody
even in your heart by desiring them
you're opening up the door so we want to
show that and and then you know in the
following series we're gonna show how to
get free so let's talk about Wonder
Woman for a few minutes here one of the
original Wonder Woman's you know
probably printed back in 1941 1942
somewhere in there I'm guessing and then
you see one of the more modern ones you
know the comic books when Wonder Woman
was quote rebirthed
and then you see the 2017 poster for the
film the film has caught a lot of
people's attention and a lot of that is
because of the actress that plays the
role and again we're not picking on her
or condemning her but we
are told in the Bible to judge the works
so what we see is being done the works
that are being portrayed in her life
were warning you against that's right
we're gonna show a single clip here and
you'll understand why
from that 2017 film
so here the dangerous thing that happens
in this one scene in this film and I do
not recommend that you watch the film
the Bible says set nothing wicked before
your eyes but in this scene Chris Pine
who's playing the hero and Wonder Woman
are in this boat and they're leaving the
island where all the Amazons live and
he's asking he prepares a place on one
end of the boat for her to go to sleep
and he starts to lay down on the other
end of the boat and she said why are you
why are you sleeping all the way over
there and he said because it's not right
for you know a man and a woman to sleep
together except in marriage and she's
like oh I don't understand that and he
was like you know don't you have
marriage you know on your on your island
he said oh I try to forgot I mean you're
all women and she's like well we don't
have marriage so he comes over and he
lays down beside her and without a lot
of encouragement it didn't take a lot to
do that but he comes over and lays down
beside her and they're there talking and
he starts asking questions about you
know how are you born I mean that's a
good topic I mean you've got an island
full of just women how did you get here
and she was like you know he said didn't
you have a father and she said no you
know my mother who is like this Amazon
she formed me out of clay and then quote
the god Zeus brought her to life yeah
that's terrifying
that's idolatry even watching the film
is idolatry and he's like you know okay
so there's no procreation or you know
something to that effect and she says
well I understand all about you know
procreation you know we've got these 12
books that talk about it
at all 12 of them and she goes on to say
as they go as they go through this
conversation the books teach them that
man is necessary for procreation only
but not necessary for physical pleasure
says that in this movie that Christians
are taking their children to go and see
and many adults are going to see and
lusting over both Chris Pine and gal
gaga and she she makes it seem like
marriage is kind of just like a dumb
concept that's a good point
and they said something in there about
Chris Pine says well when you get
married you'd go before a judge and the
first thing I thought when I saw this
clip was what about going before a
pastor you know going before the judge
is like a last resort I mean originally
you go before a pastor that's just
something to be right with the
government but to do it in God's eyes
let's go to God's house and before
that's right it's over this article and
a few years ago Grant Morrison who's one
of the more well-known comic book
writers he he wrote this series for a
lot of DC Comics that was called earth
one and so it was kind of like a
retelling of origin stories for a lot of
common superheroes woman to Ronan was
one of them so the Washington Post is
this article and the title is Grant
Morrison's new Wonder Woman you don't
just give up sex because you gave up men
and so he goes on to say in a more
explicit way what the comics really were
getting at and that you know the island
that all the women lived on was
inhabited by about 3,000 women and
there's no men there and they didn't
give up sexuality so you can connect the
dots on what that means yes it's just
crazy how it's like this stuff is really
unnecessary for the storyline in my
opinion I don't think there's any reason
to describe her sexual orientation heed
that for her to be a superhero yeah this
is a comic book that probably when it
started like you saw the little picture
a lot of parents probably trusted that
there
kids could read it and somewhat
wholesome or whatever but that's that's
what I've noticed a lot in Hollywood
with TV shows and movies and everything
they get you hooked on like the first
season or the first movie well that
wasn't that bad it was actually good so
then you watch the second one then they
throw out the agenda on you that's what
this is he's given the backstory years
later after you've already grown
attached to the character and everything
now we're going to tell you well she's
actually a lesbian and and all this
stuff well and the thing is is the whole
purpose in us looking at this in this
light is not so much about the their
their sexual preference whether it be
you know the way it was intended by our
Creator or whether it be the perverse
acts through homosexual or transgender
or bisexual but we're looking at the
fact that through these avenues these
media avenues visually you can be joined
to somebody so if that person that
you're joined to because you look at
them or you desire man it would be so
great I know women that think man Chris
Pine is like the I would love to have a
chance to be with you and they fantasize
about it yeah well if you're fantasizing
about it you've already become one with
them well if they're involved in
homosexuality and bisexuality and
transgender acts then those demons those
evil spirits that are influencing those
actions now have access to you you open
the door and gave them the right and
what's what's surprising like what what
keith was talking about what you just
said well back in the old days I can
remember I was eight years old when I
bought my first comic book my mom and
dad would not have allowed me to do that
but I had a relative that I would go and
visit them and they didn't care they
give me money and let me buy comic books
because they weren't a Christian so I
bought an Ironman and I bought Wonder
Woman and you know what was weird
I I was attracted to by the ones that
had female superheroes and you know why
because there
naked look what they wear they they
clothed them with spray-on tights you
can see I mean and every one of them has
got like you know double D size chest
and and it's spray paint and you're like
real women don't look that way
and you can see every curve to their
body God tells us in his word that a
woman should dress modestly right
covering that because those curves and
that enjoyment of looking at her figure
should be reserved for her husband
that's right that's like something
special just for him and by the same
token the men I mean you can see every
muscle every ripple in there because
they're all wearing tights yeah and you
know and this is totally off subject but
I don't know where it came from but now
it's like we've got Christian women
everywhere that are wearing yoga tights
and they may not be labeled yoga but do
you know I'm talking about the pants
that you're like yeah and I'm like why
do you not realize that that attracts
men because when they see your figure
they see your legs and your bottom and
your calf muscles and it's attractive to
the male you know why would you do that
women of old did not adorn themselves
like this or dress like this right so
along lines with what Keith just
revealed about grant Morris which I need
you to send that to me because that's
powerful
here's another interview from a magazine
called kamikaze D which is about the
comic books
in an exclusive interview Greg Rucka on
queer narrative and Wonder Woman this
was posted December or September 28 2016
right before the film came out in the
2016 interview with DC comic writer when
Greg Rucka was asked about the
possibility of the new
woman actually being queer this is what
he said yes I think it's more
complicated though this is inherently
the problem with Princess Diana or
Wonder Woman when you start to think
about giving the concept of theme
mascara it's do the answer is how can
they not all be in same-sex
relationships
right it makes no logical sense
otherwise it's supposed to be paradise
you're supposed to be able to live
happily you're supposed to be able in a
context where one lit can live happily
and part of what an individual needs for
happiness is to have a partner to have a
fulfilling romantic and sexual
relationship he says and the only
options are women but an amazonian or
Amazon doesn't look at another Amazon
and say you're gay they don't the
concept doesn't exist now are we saying
that diana has been in love and had
relationships with other women as Nicola
and I approach it the answer is
obviously yes that's the writer for the
series so that little saying that we you
know we're talking about with that boat
saying he's preparing you the writer of
this comic series for what's yet to come
there's gonna be a second movie right
yeah yeah so that's probably seen action
this year I think later in the year yes
the bane switch they didn't do it the
first one but it'll probably come out in
something the the thing there though
with the way that they're writing it is
they're trying to make it so that it's
like okay do it do away with this
thought or concept it's just normal yeah
I noticed that you know it was just it's
just the way it is just call it being
gay you call it anything it's just
they're they're in love and they have a
relationship so just some people and
we're met the other concept doesn't
exist
it's fun isn't it yeah that's right
the Bible tells us this would happen
Jesus told us actually as it was in the
days of lot or Sodom so shall it be when
the Son of Man you know returns in
Revelation 14 it tells us that another
angel followed saying Babylon is fallen
is fallen that great city because she
has made all the nations drink of the
wine of the wrath of her fornication and
that word their fornication in in that
verse
it means immorality idolatry or illicit
union with pagan gods and deities so
we're there yeah I mean if you want to
look at Hollywood idol worship I mean
there's a lot of that think about that
there was another comic that was coming
out and we've also seen this in
portrayed in films you know in Hollywood
but also the comic book industry with
Catwoman
back in 2012 Catwoman was portrayed by
an actress named Anne Hathaway and there
was a lot of resistance to her having
the part being accepted for the part and
I'm not really sure why the resistance
was there I mean Keith you may know a
little more than on that no actually I
didn't even know that she played
Catwoman until recently I feel like I've
been under a rock yeah well praise God
we're not at the movie theater but
anyway after they played or after she
played the scene everybody was shocked
at how well the scene was done and you
know I hate to say it but like you look
at again the suit that she's wearing you
know the outfit it's skin tight she has
a mask over her face which is that
something that's not good either because
that's used by a lot of people it's like
you can just sort of like well they have
a relationship with somebody for one
night without going
there is a cult orgy parties and stuff
it's a kind of just hide your identity
and so you can get away with what
happens in Vegas stays in Vegas time
right right I found out that her and her
husband they are donating and it was
this was open they are donating large
portions of the sale of their marriage
pictures to promote the ability for
homosexual marriage or for gay marriage
and yeah so I mean they're like printing
their wedding photos and selling and and
they're using a large portion of that
money too now isn't it strange that they
that they can actually do that like what
if I want to sell my wedding photos to
graze a whole bunch of money I probably
wouldn't get a sin but the fact that
these people are idols they can actually
sell their photograph of their wedding
day and make enough money to push this
agenda I know so that tells me what's in
their heart so if people are looking at
her with desire what is what does she
got in her heart do you're attaching
yourself to what's coming with those
wedding pictures Oh
Deuteronomy chapter 32 and I've got a
picture that I found and this was you
know of a perfume and it's actually
called hypnotic poison this is what the
Bible says for their vine is the vine of
Sodom and of the fields of Gomorrah
their grapes are the grapes of gall or
poison and bile and their clusters are
bitter that means they're fermented
their wine is the poison of Dragons and
the cruel venom of ASPs so through
attachment to these figures in these and
it can be even a little child looking at
a comic book yeah I can remember when
when my wife and I had went through the
separation and divorce and I was living
in an apartment I used to have my son
and my daughter they would come and
spend at least three or four days with
me every week and one day my son and I
were there at the apartment together
and I remember I was in the other room
cleaning or doing something and I heard
my little boys slam something down on
the table and he said that's not
appropriate hmm and my little boy was
like five or six I mean I was little and
I was like what in the world did he find
in the apartment I went in there and
there was a JC Penney's catalog back
when they still had catalogs you know
that's a big thick heavy book and I was
like Connor what did you find
he said daddy I can't believe they would
do that and I was like what was it and
he flipped back through the pages and
there it was on the women's
undergarments where they sell bras and
underwear and stuff and there was a
woman that they were showing I'm one of
the models as she had her underwear and
bra on and he said that was not
appropriate and he knew out of the
mouths of babes right there this was an
article from MSNBC News Online 2015 this
was the comic book writer for the new
Catwoman series says series writer
Genevieve Valentin confirmed that cat
woman's long time and literal flirtation
with bisexuality was real she said quote
for me this wasn't a revelation so much
as a confirmation the more we talked
about Catwoman being bisexual the more
it was something I wanted to make happen
so you're seeing and then they get an
actress that is at least Pro home up the
homosexuality yeah it's it's not by
chance so it's like the more we see
these kind of things the more it becomes
normal yes eventually I'm always just
reminded of Madonna saying that she
tells you that surgeon did it every
music video every concert performance
she purposely puts homosexuals out there
because she said at first that might
seem disgusting to the audience
but then it was seem normal but then
it'll eventually become appealing yeah
you see us so many times and that's
where we're at in society there's a time
when it was taboo and maybe even discuss
people are disgusted by it but now it's
like well it's just another character
you know but yeah it's when you see
younger people they're I mean okay I
just met somebody through the internet
and they're telling me that they're
they're trying to wit like be a good
influence on their nieces and nephews
because their parents aren't Christian
and these kids are like in fourth grade
and and she recorded a conversation they
were having and they they said oh you
didn't know he was gay yeah he's gay and
they're talking about a kid at school oh
right
and they're just like yeah some people
are gay and some people are you know
it's sad too because we're looking at
why is this wet so widespread I mean
like with people even young people that
are saying man I don't know what I am I
don't know what my preference is and I
mean young people why well have they
been idolizing these figures and if
these figures are living that kind of
lifestyle or entertaining that lifestyle
and these children are idolizing them or
these adults are idolizing them the
connection has made the tie can be made
this one was one that really surprised
me the new Man of Steel you know
obviously the the the the new figure I
mean he's probably done one of the best
jobs I think of playing or portraying
you know Superman but then the woman
that plays the part of Lois Lane who is
his you know his love she was played by
an actress named Amy Adams and you know
the film came out a number of years ago
2013 the first one but I saw the first
time I saw her was when I was watching a
preview of the space movie or the alien
movie called the arrival or arrival
and when I saw her I thought you know
just the first thought just looking at
her I thought she's an attractive lady
but it was this different kind of
attractive it was like a simple like a
farm girl or a natural I didn't have any
idea what she had been involved in she
actually I actually saw a film clip I
think in the film clip it showed her
kissing gal gadot and I may not be wrong
either they were talking about it or it
showed them you know kiss and it wasn't
like a long drawn-out kiss but it still
it shocked me and then I just thought I
want to look and see for this series if
she had any involvement with bisexuality
so I just typed you know her name in and
and that subject matter and there were
numerous seen pictures and scenes of her
kissing a woman she was the one that
played in a film I believe it was called
cruel intentions number two where she
played in a lesbian scene of Campbell
yeah I guess that was his name but she
played in these parts so somebody can
tell me well I'm not bisexual or I'm not
a lesbian but I played the part of one
you can't do the action unless that
desire or that feeling is there and if
you're able to do it and be that
disconnected that's even worse than if
you were in bondage yeah so in my heart
I was like I've got to start praying for
her because she's married you know
probably got children just like gal
gadot I think she was pregnant in the
first film they had to hide you know her
stomach because of that what did you
find anything key no so anyway what I'm
saying is just because a person may look
innocent and homegrown and that doesn't
mean they are I had no idea she'd ever
played in that kind of a film again in
Revelation 18 it says Babylon has fallen
this fall
and has become the habitation of devils
in the Bible
Jerusalem represents God's people look
it up in Daniel chapter 9 read Daniel
chapter 9 and it describes God's people
as that mountain and that that city
which is called by thy name
God's people the holy people are called
Jerusalem the unholy and those that have
not surrendered to the call of God are
called Babylon and it says they are
become the habitation of devils and the
hold of every foul spirit a cage of
every unclean and hateful bird now we're
gonna bring this to a close I want to
show you a lot of people look at these
Hollywood stars and they say they've got
it
I mean they're making all the money in
the world they've got all the women or
all the men they want that you know they
are it this was an actor Heath Ledger
that was he was like everybody knew this
guy is gonna make the world I mean he
was like he was handsome he was
clean-cut everybody thought Australian
actor he only lived 28 years old and
what was so scary to me was is I saw
back when I was living a lukewarm
Christian life and I still was watching
Hollywood movies I mean I would go home
after church and when the Sun went down
I would cut Hollywood on as long as they
weren't saying you know really really
bad words or blaspheming God and I
remember seeing him play in a couple of
films like a Knight's Tale and some
others and for me I was so blinded by
Satan and by sin even as a Christian I
didn't see anything wrong with watching
those and then I remember when he
decided to play in a film that was it
was terrible it was called broke bout
Brokeback Mountain
and even in mice even in the city you
know where near where I lived Johnson
City there were Christians that were
protesting outside the theater when the
theaters began advertising that it was
coming I mean like they were holding
signs and they weren't yelling and
screaming but they were walking and they
were saying we're not gonna stand for
this you know this needs to not come to
this this town or the city but it was
about two Cowboys and their homosexual
relationship and it was probably one of
the first or groundbreaking films that
had come out openly and was shown openly
in a regular theater yeah after he
played that part he was offered the part
some time I don't know the distance in
time but he was offered the part to play
the Joker and he willingly accepted it
because he was like man I want to make I
want to make my name in the earth
through playing this part because for an
actor to play the same role over and
over again or the same character and
that's all they do there's no money in
that they want to be like man I played
the good guy I played the bad guy I
played the saint I acted like the devil
the first time yeah so he he set himself
that I'm gonna be the best Joker that's
ever been and he got a phone call from
Jack Nicholson who had also played the
Joker and Jack Nicholson says that he
warned him you know don't take this part
because Jack Nicholson knows from years
and years of being and acting to play a
part
correctly you have to become the part
and the only way to do that is to open
yourself up what's it called method
acting yeah so anyway from what I heard
and what I've read he went into a hotel
room for you know three four weeks or so
I think it was close to 40 days do you
remember Keith he had went into a hotel
room and locked himself in that hotel
room away from his wife and family away
from everybody and for four weeks or 40
days somewhere in that air
and during that time he wrote that the
only thing he did was he watched and
read and listen to everything he could
about Psychopaths and mentally disturbed
people rapists
I mean watched and read so that he could
understand what was going on in the mind
of this character of the Joker talk
about you know by beholding you become
changed and he's just like I want to
become possessed basically I'm just
gonna put all this stuff in me and so
that I can play this part and look where
it brought him you know yeah and I don't
remember how long after I know it was a
very short time after they completed the
filming they found him dead from suicide
I thought I was actually still being
filmed I thought it was but seems like
somebody had told me that that it was
you know a few weeks or a month
afterward but we can do we can do
research on that but the point being is
a 28 year old young man whom God wanted
to be with him in heaven and the devil
snuffed his life out by by attaching
himself so how many young girls or old
women or middle-aged women were
attracted to him and how many desired
him in their heart and if he was in
bondage that bondage could have been
brought into their life
now let's look at Ruby Rose again we're
coming to wind it down this is a picture
of Ruby Rose and this was from Fox News
and listen to what they said about her
Ruby Rose opens up about her depression
and past suicide attempts for World
Mental Health Day when I saw this
picture and I looked it up I wanted to
find out about her I saw a picture that
they had taken of her when she was in
the hospital after one of these
attempted suicide and it broke my heart
because you her eyes are looking at the
camera there's none of that glamour
and makeup and all that junk and I saw a
little girl that was screaming somebody
please help me
and I found an interview and she did not
come straight out and say that she had
been she didn't come straight out and
say what had happened but she indicated
very strongly that someone in her family
a male figure had hurt her deeply when
she was a little girl heart and it did
it changed me just seeing that one
picture God spoke to me and said Eric
quit trying to destroy them and start
praying for them so I am sharing about
some of the stuff that these actors and
actresses are doing but I'm sharing the
dangers of the action and I'm asking you
all of you all of us to pray for them
yeah because what if God got into her
life what if her eyes were opened to
hear or to see his glory and what he
sees her ass and her ears were open to
hear his voice she could turn millions
to Christ yeah we need to pray for that
this is a picture of her same girl that
you saw in the other slide that's her
same tattoos and you look in her eyes
and you you think I wish I could talk to
her I wish I could send her an email or
a book how can we reach people like this
and share with them the glad tidings of
what Jesus has done I think I'm gonna
read to you a short quote the only
begotten Son of God looked upon these
schemes by which Satan works to blot
from the human soul every trace of
likeness to God he saw human beings
possessed with Devils he saw satanic
agencies incorporated with men
the very stamp of demons was impressed
upon the countenances of men and women
and human faces reflected the expression
of the legions thousands of evil angels
with which they were possessed
then came Jesus to restore in man the
image of his maker he knows that a demon
power is struggling in every soul
it could be selfishness it could be
pride it could be rejection
it could be bitterness it could be lying
it could be hopelessness and despair he
knows that a demon power is struggling
in every soul striving for the Dominion
and the reign in their life but Jesus
came to break the power of Satan and set
the captives free he came for but one
purpose and that was the salvation of
the Lost that word salvation literally
means freedom and rescued deliverance
and healing and restoration and he says
in Hosea Oh Israel that's you and I if
we will but believe him thou has
destroyed thyself but in me is thine
help I will be thy King for where is any
other that may save thee in all of thy
cities I will ransom you from the power
of the grave I will redeem you from
death Oh death I will be thy plagues Oh
grave I will be thy destruction and
repentance shall be hid from mine eyes
for I will not change my mind
Christ wants to set the captives free
and all we have to do is get on our
knees and confess to him what we've done
was wrong and ask him to cleanse us and
wash us with the blood of his son and
he's faithful and just to forgive us our
sins and cleanse us of all
unrighteousness
hallelujah ask right hallelujah you know
a practical note mmm you know if you're
struggling with beholding something that
you shouldn't a lot of that comes
through I guess excess free time that we
give ourselves you know if you stay busy
you're a lot less likely to get in
trouble that's right if you're or if you
purposefully occupy your time with
something to do that could be you know
it could be reading the Bible it could
be hanging out with other people it
could be you know taking an online class
I mean there's so many ways that you can
fill your time with things that are good
and edifying and uplifting exercise yeah
I exercise that you don't have that you
fill that space with something else so
that you don't have that time to where
your mind wanders or you find yourself
being drawn into a temptation so I would
say a practical step is stay busy you
cannot throw something in with that and
along with what Keith said if you have
found that there's problems with a
computer put the computer out in the
open where you're with other people
never have the computer in a room where
you're by yourself put the computer
where it's in the kitchen and mom and
dad or your brothers and sisters or your
roommates it's right there and it's not
that this is taking the place of Christ
but like he said this is a practical way
to help you to to be able to find some
freedom and occupy your time with God's
work and there's software that helps
with that too there's things like
covenant I
you know you install it on your devices
and then it sends a report to an
accountability partner and they see what
it is that you're looking at so you know
if you decide or choose to look at
something that you shouldn't they're
gonna know that and they're gonna be
able to approach you about it and say
hey brother or sister what can we do to
remedy this and help you out so that's
just one example there are others all
kinds of things that you can do a
practical level you want to know more
about those kind of things contact us
and maybe we can send you some resources
and some suggestions in the practical
realm so this has been another episode
of LED live thank you Eric for talking
to us about to be here sold highs and
how we're affected by the things that we
see and that spiritual connection that
can be created so we hope to catch you
next time and don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share this episode
with somebody who needs it this has been
LED live we'll see you again
[Music]